[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
joining me here on just getting started
is a man i'm pleased to call a friend uh
known him for many a moon long before he
was a star of 9-1-1 lone star which is
coming up on season three on fox in the
fall
and a show that we watch is a family
here in the eisenhower mental samurai
with all new episodes tuesdays at 9 8
central only on fox the host of the
literally with rob lowe podcast as well
rob lowe how are you rob i'm really good
i'm excited to
to see this new this new podcast that
you're doing it's
yeah so many talents and a lot i
appreciate that i appreciate that you
normally come on my
my daily show um radio and tv but i
figured
i'd love to have you on here too because
i i wanted to start a podcast
that was a little bit different than
what i do as well as give people
a little bit of uh guidance if they need
it
uh on just getting started with their
lives if it's been paused or changed in
any way or they want
some sort of uh portable piece of advice
from anybody
because everybody's got an origin story
like you rob lowe ever you have an
origin story
right well we're all the whole world is
restarting
so it's the time to do it right exactly
right
so uh how did you just get started rob
how did that start for you well i was
really
really really i think lucky
there's a curse to it which i'll get to
yes but
lucky blessed that i knew very very
young what i wanted to do
like i knew in my dna
that i wanted to be an actor by the time
i was eight
i knew that and i'd gone to see a
neighborhood local theater company with
my parents
and there were kids in the play the play
was oliver
and the kids were playing whatever the
lost boys where the hell they
kids are over and i was like i want to
do
that yeah and i'm sure my parents were
just like
sure just like i want to play little
league or i'd like to go on a canoe trip
or i'd like to
but i'm sure they thought it was like a
passing fancy but i knew that's what i
wanted to do and
and and literally podcast
title literally um everything i did in
my life
from that moment on was directed
at that um my total soul focus
and um how did you get your first big
break then
how did that come about rob for those
who might not have read your
your book like i did which is much must
read
because uh i'll say this as i mentioned
before about
your your first i should say book um
it's clear nobody else wrote it it's
clear that you sat down and wrote it it
literally is in your voice to use that
phrase literally as well
so for those who might not already know
the story go for it
if you don't mind well thank you and i
and i do welcome very proud of the books
and i always love when people
you know because if you have any
interest in me at all
the books are really fun because it is
it's the most
pure essence you know of me anyway
um so i you know i did i did local
theater
i did camp theater any type of theater
you could do i did
and my notion was when i grew up
i would go to new york and hit the
bricks in new york like because i was
doing
i was playing every little kid part in
every university play
university of wright state university
university of dayton
i was living in dayton ohio the kenley
players were that were around then which
was like a summer stock professional
so i was like the kid you went to and i
and everybody there was going to new
york and they were theater actors
well my parents got divorced which i was
not happy about that was not a
a good moment for my family but
uh what it brought was my mom relocating
to los
angeles so the lesson for me
um is you know there really is
you know there's a plan for everything
and
i hated coming to la i hated it i missed
my friends
i missed ohio um i'm the only idiot that
would rather have been in dayton ohio
than malibu
but the fact that i was able to that i
was in la
you know i started hitting the bricks
and taking the bus from
point doom i would i would uh do my
homework
on the bus after school and go all the
way into hollywood three different bus
lines and do an audition and
come back get home for dinner and go to
bed and repeat as many
times as as i needed it and i was just
you know i mean i was blessed with the
drive that's for
sure and ignorance yes ignorance
why is ignorance such an important part
rob because you didn't know any better
that you should stop trying or something
like that or is that version
i here's a stat that every time i tell
it
i think it's [ __ ] and then i
like re-look it up and go no it's it's
real and that is
we have a thing as you know you're
probably a member you remember the
screen actors guild
yes sir i am how else can i star in
two episodes of csi miami that nets me
on
average 80 cents a check rob every
single time i open that envelope
i know isn't it exciting to see those 80
cent checks
hold on i literally have literally here
we go i've got one here
um it's for this let i just open this
one up it's 14 bucks man
14 congratulations the kids
are gonna love that dinner
based off of that right there so i guess
i understand what
i don't even know the statistic you're
about to tell me but i can i can believe
every last word of it that's
you know it's not going to be a good one
so the screen actors guild
which um to even get in the screen
actors guild
you have to be a working actor
of the members of the screen actors
guild
do you know what percentage rich
fully support themselves at acting
is it akin to a milk bottle of that
percentage
is it something close to that rob so
i'll put a g this way 97
of the screen actors build do not make
enough money
as an actor to support themselves 97
percent now if somebody had told me
those numbers when i was an
eight-year-old right wanting to get into
acting
i i i mean our you know when i was
when i decided not to go to college and
do my first
movie role my parents had sat me down
and said look we'll support you
not going to college your freshman year
but you need to know
you got to start paying for [ __ ] and 97
of the screen actors guild can't do that
and support themselves i don't know what
i would have done so ignorance
was a was great for me yeah like you're
those those
athletes that you know uh don't know
what they don't know but that's how
maybe you can be successful is that you
don't know what you don't know and you
just follow your gut
you follow your dream and keep the
blinders on and
obviously you can get an opportunity you
know and the other part of it because
then the shoe was on the other foot with
my own kids
right so fast forward 25 year whatever
how many years later it is
and my kids are like telling me what
they want to do with their lives
one of them was a very talented musician
and i was like that's the worst business
that makes acting look like uh
investment banking
um and i
had the talk with them i did i i had the
talk with them that my parents didn't
with me i was like
listen you just need to know this is
what you're facing and you're going
into it a business that's tough and that
is
going through such fight it's always
been tough in the heyday and it's not
the heyday anymore
um so the other part of it though
is is you know is the why not me
it's got to be somebody why not me you
know
there has to be that small percentage
that makes it why not me
so it cuts both ways whatever mantra you
want to use
but i've thought of them both believe me
[Music]
back with rob lowe in a moment school's
out for summer people but if your
business is running quickbooks you'll
never get a break
quickbooks manual processes and
integration difficulties and glitchy
delays will leave you scrambling for the
numbers you need
failing to graduate to netsuite will
leave you stuck in summer school while
your friends party
netsuite by oracle is the number one
cloud financial system no matter how big
your business grows
with visibility and control of your
financials inventory hr e-commerce and
more
netsuite is everything you need to grow
all in one place
automate your processes with netsuite
and close your books in no time
93 of surveyed businesses increased
their visibility and control since
graduating from quickbooks
to netsuite special financing is back
people netsuite is offering a
one-of-a-kind financing program only
for those ready to graduate today head
to netsuite.com
eisen right now that's special financing
at netsuite.com
e-i-s-e-n netsuite dot com slash eisen
so who were you taking the bus with
anyone we know
anybody that uh in your in your other
goofs ever wanted to be actors i started
that damn trend
okay well they all slip streamed the kid
from ohio
i rode up on malibu and charlie sheen
was
throwing you know 80 mile an hour
fastballs in the backyard
you know literally he threw he could
throw 80 miles an hour in
uh in high school really like so
the wild thing is real is what you're
saying he'll be a baseball player
he's gonna be a pro baseball player for
sure and going to you know
travel teams all that stuff he want to
be a baseball player
um sean penn hadn't done any acting yet
really and or cr his brother chris
and emilio i think kind of wanted to act
but i arrived there wanting to do it and
then you know they came on their own and
figured it out but um
i was alone on that bus i had no i had
no
no friends and that was a lonely lonely
lonely back
so you're saying like in your spare time
you go over to the sheen's house you
knock on the door and martin opens the
door and you're like is charlie here or
is it
is that basically what your your
childhood was like something like that
absolutely well martin was never there
because he was away doing this
movie called apocalypse now
and it was i remember just knowing
growing up with that
that title in my head because my
friend's dad was
never home i lived in i lived next door
to them for two years before i ever saw
him
are you serious because he was in the
[ __ ] with marlon brando is that
basically it that's why you never saw
him
yeah you live next door apocalypse now
damn man
legend they don't make movies like that
anymore i can tell you that
oh man so um okay
so that's your that's your your and your
first big break was what what was the
the one movie that was your your first
big break rob
i kind of have three big breaks well the
first one is the very first paying job
you get and the very first paying job
i got professionally was i was in the
first commercial that was ever
made specifically for the super bowl
get out of here i never knew that which
what was that
it's for coke for coca-cola okay
and um it was really ahead of its time
it probably okay i'm trying to think
what year would it would have been 1977
and it was what they call a wanter
so it's all one shot they built a
four-story new york tenement
on a soundstage in culver city and at a
big crane and at the beginning
of the commercial i came out with a
bunch of kids in the stoop
playing handball and i heard stinging
from up on the roof
i pointed to the top of the roof and
that
motivated the camera rich don't you see
and the camera then went up the building
and looked in every
window as people were enjoying their
coca-colas
slices of life just americans just doing
what they do
drinking coke and then the camera got to
the top of the building
and there was a guy playing his guitar
singing the coca-cola song
with the beautiful new york city skyline
it was very lyrical and i think it aired
twice
during this which super bowl was it do
you remember sitting around watching the
super bowl and here comes your
commercial on the air
do you remember that i remember seeing
it on the air once it must have been the
super bowl
um but it and i used to watch and watch
it
so 77 who would that have been was that
the original it sounds like a cowboy
steelers match up
it sounds like a cowboy steelers matchup
to me rob like if i had to
guess yeah that reeks of bradshaw
starback
yes rob lowe coca-cola triumvirate that
i didn't know actually existed
until just now here on this that was my
first and then i
i would go to my mailbox and get those
residuals like you just opened up and be
so excited
um and then um and then i i did uh
oh then my next big break was i got a
carl's jr commercial
uh-huh oh this is the difference between
coming to la and going to new york
had i gone to new york as i thought in
ohio i would have been like in death of
a salesman
sure yeah or you know i'd have done
pinter
but instead i go to la and i'm working
with regis philbin
on a carl's jr commercial that's
regis was in that commercial come on rob
regis was at that point the um
the sort of the biggest star on i think
kabc
i don't know if he he was you know like
the local
whatever the hell like he was the guy
but he was regional
he was he was totally a regional star
and um we did uh we did a carl's jr
commercial together
and and then i went unemployed for like
a hundred years after that
and uh my next big break
um and this is it so i fell in love for
the first time ever
i was 14 you know that puppy love where
you just can't see straight
you're truly love sick
like sick in love and it was just as i
had to go to ohio
in the summer to see my dad and
i didn't want to go back to ohio because
i just fall in love with this beautiful
beautiful beautiful
blonde surfer girl i get to ohio i'm
despondent and my agent calls me and my
agent was like a shitty
little rinky dink like waiting for
guffman
type agent and calls me as like
so there's a tv show that we think you'd
be right for if you want to audition
i use that an excuse to pay for my own
flight to fly back to l.a
to audition for just to be with the
girlfriend
again never knowing it's just an
audition
it's just they don't know who i am they
i get it
i get the tv show and i only got it
because i came back because i wanted to
be with my girlfriend
and that was my first big
it was called a new kind of family it
was on abc it was
directly opposite 60 minutes which meant
we were
truly dead last i'm not
truly there were 62 shows in existence
that's all there were three networks in
those days that was it 62 shows on the
schedule
we were 62nd every week dead last crush
curb stomped by morley safer but
you at least came back and you were with
the girl that you wanted to hang with
and that was and those three things
together has helped what launched
your career well and then this very day
so then that shows a disaster right a
total total
unmitigated disaster in spite of the
fact it was produced by michael eisner's
wife
and and larry gordon's wife right
those titans of the industry yes um
and um it was about two families sharing
the same house
they shut us down the ratings were so
bad they fired the other family
and decided to make the new family black
figuring that was the problem and so now
without explaining where the other
family went
and janet jackson was now the new little
girl on the show
yes and i remember talking to janet and
she was like this acting thing sucks
she's like she's like i think if this
doesn't work i'm just going to be a
straight singer
[Music]
so janet and i did that show together
then i didn't work again
for like three or four
years and i figured my career was over
i had a moment i was a child actor and
didn't make it and i was
studying to be a marine biologist
because i love the ocean
and i love that kind of thing and i'm
kind of a nerd that way so
my thought was i'll either be a lawyer
or a marine biologist
and i was auditioning and not getting
anything and ready to quit and
um was got accepted at usc
and was ready to um go there and i got
the outsiders
the day i had to choose my classes
for usc and uh way i did the uh
i did the movie instead and that was
that
the rest is history so the outsiders
comes
knocking on your door as you're choosing
your curriculum
to tap out of acting like i'm gonna
study
um invertebrates in the intertidal zone
from first period
[Applause]
quick pause in my chat with my buddy rob
lowe to tell you about linkedin
today many small business owners are
busier than ever
because they're focused on managing and
growing their business they can't always
spend the time they wish they could
on recruiting and that's why linkedin
jobs
has made it easier to find and hire the
best candidates
for free get started by posting your job
for free to reach linkedin's network of
740
million professionals fill out targeted
screening questions to get your role in
front of the most qualified candidates
with the experience skills and
motivation you need
then use simple tools to filter and
prioritize the top candidates you'd like
to interview
linkedin jobs will help you hire the
right person for your role and
your first job post is free just visit
linkedin.com
rich that's linkedin.com rich to post
your first job for free
terms and conditions apply
[Applause]
do you ever sit around i mean outside of
a podcast where
questions are asked if you like this rob
and ever sit back and go
holy [ __ ] like how tenuous is this i
mean like
everything that you're you're looking
around and seeing from your current
projects to
some of the most iconic pop culture
touchstone
movies that people identify
with not just themselves personally but
their time and their lives and what they
were doing
and things of that nature that this all
could have been
not happening does that ever hit you at
all
i could be out on a dredge on the
marianas trench right now
looking looking for geodes
or whatever instead of doing this
podcast with you
and but you know but we all know life
changes in a blink of an eye
you know no matter who we are and
it's it's the same for me and and
it's a function of who you meet what you
say
luck preparation drive
ambition ignorance knowledge
all those things go into a stew
and you know get it gets mixed up by the
man upstairs and
if it's a good mix you're you're you're
going to be good to go but
it's like the question is how much of it
do we really control
and you know we can only control what's
right in front of us
and i mean right in front of us so you
know the day
in ohio when i got the phone call from
my agent uh my control of it was
i'm going back to california to see my
girlfriend and oh by the way i
auditioned for this
tv show by the way that's the only way i
got the outsiders i learned later
that coppola was so broke talking about
apocalypse now
yes um after
the you know apocalypse and this movie
won from the heart which was a huge bomb
and he bought a studio went belly up
they had to make a hit
so his idea was to make like a teen idol
movie
and the outsiders was going to be that
and he hired
a woman her name is michelle manning
she's an executive to this day a friend
of mine
to go to 7-eleven and pick out all the
teen magazines
and who's ever had the most pictures in
the magazines went up on a board
casting board and that's how he started
the casting process
i'm only in those teen magazines because
of my failed
sitcom and if i'm not in that i'm not on
the board and if i'm not on the board i
don't know if coppola auditions me
so all you know it all is interconnected
in ways we never know
and the cast in that film as well i mean
is uh
you know a tremendous cast and people
who
um you you know uh are associated with
you know whether it's pop culture or in
other ways to this day
rob i mean when you look at the cast of
the outsiders
period you know um you know
there's a man by the name of fred roose
who is
was and is francis coppola's producing
partner but really what fred does is
cast
the first movie that fred cast was
american graffiti
i've heard of that the second movie he
cast was
um the godfather um
he also cast apocalypse now and then he
casts the outsiders
so if you do the you yeah i know you're
a cinephile
you talk about it's harrison ford in um
american graffiti um you know it's duval
it's all these people
and he so he found us fred roose
found all of us and um crews and
everybody in the whole
the whole i mean that is that is truly
unbelievable
um rob lowe here on just getting started
let's talk about the here and now
um mental samurai um
is rob on in this house
it is no seriously because you can't in
this day and age there's
there's not a lot that families can just
you know my kids are
12 10 and seven that they we all can
agree like let's just sit down let's
watch this and i also know i'm not going
to get assaulted
you know with the kids too and you know
they they they can get some of the first
answers right
too you know and then and then
you know question seven or eight we go
off the deep end with everybody else
you know and it's it's quite something
um
did were you always like a reality show
or game show
uh guy or like to forget an opportunity
for something
like this i mean so when i was doing the
failed
janet jackson sitcom to help promote it
it's all connected i love it this is all
connected
they sent me to my very first time in
new york on my own
to play a celebrity version with dick
clark of the ten thousand dollar pyramid
by the way how funny is ten thousand
dollar pyramid
you can't buy a car for that
hell of a pyramid hell of a pair up here
but i crushed
i mean in all modesty it's like ty cobb
said
it ain't bragging if you'd done it damn
straight
who were you who are you paired with do
you remember who was the other
giver of clues and stuff like that i was
it was i was up against tony danza
again somebody who you probably have
[Music]
known forever and a day you probably run
into him in dodger stadium
rob i mean and i and he's still licking
his wounds for the
shell lacking he got um
so um
so we did so i liked i like um
trivia trivia games i'm terrible puzzle
by the way this is why i would be
terrible on mental samurai
because i'd be great at one of the four
towers trivia history
memory but if i when i got to the puzzle
tower
i would be done literally done i can't
do sudoku
i can't do any of i can't do tetris
right i can't do any
my mind doesn't work that way and what i
love about mental samurai is you have to
you have to have every facet of
knowledge yeah to win
oh yeah and so this is something
you could see how you're enjoying it
like this has got to be a total blast
part of me was also born to give away
cash and prizes rob
that's why i think i'm on this planet
you know so
there's nothing like that dude making
people happy is awesome
and watching people win making people
happy
um being a cheerleader because that's
the fun of it is to cheerlead the people
and to to sit there and die
inside when for ten thousand dollars
it's
name this iconic 90s
sitcom and then there's an anagram
it clearly says friends it's an anagram
but it's friends it's 90s iconic sitcom
and the three minutes they stare at it
and don't know it and finally i say
you've gotta make
you gotta at least take a guess because
i'm gonna go with derpins
i wanted that shirt made in that classic
friends font
yeah this is earphone
could you and did you say could you be
anymore wrong
you know just use the channel
this 1980s duo dominated
pop the pop charts and it was a picture
of a hallway yes and a bowl of
oats and the guy was like
okay so a hall and road see up hallway
floor ball hall oh
floor whole cereal
all notes baby so fun i love the show
the show is funny funny fun fun you know
and then but it is
it is out of body for a lot of people
to do something like that that they
can't believe they're on the set or
something
along i mean you just did celebrity
family feud i imagine even just for a
split second
there's steve harvey there's the board
you know and
you're at home and you can nail this
stuff if you're at home but once you're
in the crucible of actually being there
i imagine even for you who's been there
and done pretty much everything that's
still a little bit
i couldn't hit the buzzer i didn't hit
the buzzer one
now once did i hit the buzzer it was not
easy
i mean listen they said
you know name a name a plant you don't
want to touch you want to go with
popular answers it's all
point of the show you're right plant you
don't want to touch i go with venus
flytrap what the hell's going on with me
name a plant you wouldn't want to touch
oh boy
yeah well you don't want to touch it
well you don't but nobody knows what the
hell it is you said
the very the very popular venus fly trap
survey said
okay cactus and poison ivy
tied for the top well we have some nice
parting gifts for you rob you know you
and your family
that's right fantastic
this episode of just getting started is
sponsored by home
made a podcast from rocket mortgage
about the meaning of home and what it
can teach us
about ourselves and others the show is
really enjoyable
these are provocative poignant even
hilarious stories that explore the
diversity of home in america
and the fundamental need for shelter and
belonging that unites us all
michael wood lewis moved to this great
neighborhood hoping to become friends
with his new neighbors but that didn't
exactly happen
until he built his own social network to
make friends all across vermont
in another episode shaheen pasha
searches for someone known to her
immigrant family only as
the landlady who 30 years earlier had
rescued them from homelessness when they
arrived from pakistan
but the search takes shaheen deep into
possibly unfriendly territory
the stories from home made will inspire
you as much as they did me
so search for home made anywhere you
listen to podcasts that's two words
you can tell throughout this
conversation home
and made home and made my thanks to home
made for their support on this podcast
[Applause]
how are you enjoying podcasting with
literally with roblo a highly popular
pod that's on the uh
the conan o'brien label if i'm not
mistaken
it's a team coco stitcher
but anywhere in your podcast i'm lo i'm
loving it loving it i i thought
i would like it i didn't know i would
love it
and what i'm loving about it
is just like what we're doing now the
you know the long form
discussion right um is just the best
you know usually other than podcasts
people are on talk shows and talk shows
today
are about games and you know promoting
your movie and you never really get into
the weeds with anybody on anything
and on podcasts you have to and
and i just like taking the conversations
wherever wherever they're gonna go and
getting people to talk about stuff
that they have never talked about before
because i'm not asking them the
questions that everybody else is asking
i mean
i literally had oprah on two weeks ago
and you know she's oprah for
i was halfway through the conversation i
was like
this is why she's [ __ ] oprah winfrey
because she's what caused you to say
that what what
what was the part of the conversation
can we just know how to talk
does that engage knows how to
bring it do you i mean there's a reason
she's oprah winfrey
and right halfway through that
conversation i'm like overwhelmed with
it
but i didn't ask her about prince harry
and megan merkel
now maybe i should be fired for that
there's a world in which they go
i'm sorry you had oprah winfrey on and
you didn't ask her about interviewing
prince harry or meghan markle
and i'm like you don't need me to do
that a stringer from e-channel can do
that
right so i kind of
pride myself on you know the unexpected
and and it's been it's really fun and so
far people really like it
who do you want on whoever you who would
you want on your pod that you have yet
to have on
um uh lauren
michaels i just haven't asked him i'm
scared
to ask it's like to call in favors for
it's funny the people that you're
comfortable calling in the favors on
right and then there's the people that
you're kind of like i don't know
and i just simply haven't asked alone
yet and but i will because he's
he comes up in almost every podcast
because i have a lot of snl people on
and i love snl and i have a lot of
comedians on who maybe weren't even on
snl but inevitably that
topic comes up and so he's kind of like
the
you know the great white whale of the
show um
well i'm just sitting here rob i'm just
sitting here thinking first of all you
were in wayne's world if i'm not
mistaken has to be the highest grossing
film
that any of his characters has ever uh
endeavored that's number one number two
um
if i'm not mistaken he's owned the conan
o'brien
spot for years on nbc before all of that
occurred he must have a piece of your
podcast like literally
in on literally he would be literally
making money
by boosting your downloads that i mean i
could i could write the pitch for you
rob if you you know
if you want maybe i'm just i i'm i'm
scared to ask
dad
um yes sir and then the other would be
springsteen and i've been trying to get
that going
um i know you're a big bruce fan as am i
and
um hey what you got what are you gonna
pull over there i see you going
this is from my wife who's a die hard
springsteen fan she was working out on
the upper west side about 20 some odd
years ago
and he was working out there she ran
home and got her
uh her album cover of
um going to run right here
and uh and he signed it i mean
that's it that's the man
he would be great and if i can't get
either one of them eventually what i'm
going to do is i'm just going to do
a podcast where i play both of them
will know and here's how it would go
ready yes
please um lauren um tell me about
the first time you met dan aykroyd you
know rob the thing about danny
is he's much taller in real life than
you think he is
and then i'll be like hey bruce so tell
me
what was your relationship like with
clarence clements
the big man he's a force to be reckoned
with
so lauren michaels really does sound
like dr evil then it's basically what
you're saying
he really does like that really was not
even
i don't think anybody pretends otherwise
now including lorne himself okay so
hold on a second maybe i'm wrong austin
powers might be his
greatest um thing
um but that wasn't an snl character
that was all mr mike myers mm-hmm
okay so you've been in it i mean if you
could
not be i may or may not be doing a
surprise
appearance in his new netflix show that
was announced today
okay rob lowe that's a great little
piece of a breadcrumb that'll be for the
next time
you're on promoting anything here on
this show so um
and before i let you go um if you could
revisit one of your characters to see
what he is up to
today any of them in the history of your
filmography televisionography if that's
even a word
who would that character be to revisit
who that person is and what they are
doing in 2021
who would that be ro
how about that one there are a lot of
characters that are in second place
but there's only one in first place okay
with that and that's i don't know if you
were aware that from time to time i
would come in and
have a lot of fun with my buddy david
covney on his show californication
and i played a character named eddie
nero okay
and eddie nero was a polysexual
um drug adult academy award-winning
pretentious movie star and
it was the most by far the most insane
character i've ever had the opportunity
to play
and i can only the mind
boggles at what eddie nero
would be doing today okay so
it's your california i would have i
would not have guessed that one
i mean um uh what about about last night
what do you think well listen there's
listen there's certainly danny from
about last night and billy from st
elmo's fire but i kind of know what
they'd be doing that's
what are they doing are they dads are
they dads now or what are
what danny's for sure dad i think danny
and debbie got together again
and were they you know at that long bike
ride in
grant park they hooked up and they've
got kids and they're happy as a young
clams i think
i think billy hicks and st almost fire
went to new york and got his big break
playing the saxophone just as that
moment in the 80s when saxophones became
banned from all songs
like every song out of saxo every single
one
literally every one in the 80s until
one day someone said
basta no more sax solos
so my billy hicks probably is a strung
out drug addict because
the minute he got successful with his
saxophone
it was over hmm
so not so good for billy but danny's
great he's good they got kids
and sam seabourn of the west wing yes
went on to work for barack obama
and is now you know uh you know
he's a pundit somewhere don't you think
he's a pundit he's on
he's got his own show sam seabourn don't
you think
he's he's got his own hour long on some
sort of cabler
right now he's doing that he's got a pod
he's got a pod yeah he's got a pod hell
yeah he's got it stem ceilings got a pod
sam seabourn is uh yeah he's he's he's a
he's advising people he's you know
chris cuomo's looking over his back sam
seabourn
i think that's what he's doing now hey
man this is a lot of fun i appreciate it
and i know that uh
you were you were killing it um i assume
you were you were shooting
your latest season uh of what's coming
up this fall on fox of 911 lone star you
just
that's in the can as they say in the
business
911 lone star um uh we've wrapped our
second season
and we start season three
at the end of the summer and we'll be
back on the air in january
coming out of football i love when they
put us after football as you know
so you'll go right from football to our
our third season
in in january and in the meantime in the
meantime
it's all about mental samurai mental
samurai which is uh new episodes
tuesdays at 9 8 central only on fox this
fall 9-1-1 lone star
literally with rob lowe podcast which is
uh where all podcasts can be acquired
um you're the man i really appreciate it
rob you're the best
so fun thanks man this is i love this
this is a really cool idea for a pod i'm
going to do something
anytime man i appreciate uh you doing
this and i'll have you back on my show
anytime and um
you know if you want me to muscle out
bruce or
or lauren you know i'll i can i can be
literal as well whenever you need
if that's ever the time rob i just
invited myself on your podcast but
that's what people do in los angeles you
do come on baby let's do it
anytime i'd love it that's rob lowe
right here on just getting started
[Music]
[Applause]
do you own or rent your home of course
you do and i bet it can be hard work you
know what's easy
bundling policies with geico geico makes
it easy to bundle your homeowners or
renters insurance along with your auto
policy
it's a good thing too because you
already have so much to do around your
home
go to geico.com get a quote and see how
much you could save
it's geico easy visit geico.com today
that's
geico.com
[Music]
man i love roblo i've had him on several
times on the rich eisen show which by
the way you can get in the podcast
version every single day all three hours
every single day you can get it right
here on the cumulus podcast network or
wherever
podcasts are required and uh he's just
such an incredible storyteller of course
he loves
stuff like game shows and talking on a
podcast that he has he's a storyteller
his his book is his first book his
memoir
um is truly remarkable the guy has met
everyone that's why i just love he's in
a
uh a tv commercial with regis philbin
he got to meet um tom cruise in his
first film the outsiders and patrick
swayze and he lived next door to charlie
sheen and emilio estevez i mean my god
his
his his story is amazing i i did not
know about him going back home to dayton
i knew he was from dayton ohio but i did
not know about that moment where he went
back home to dayton and he was miserable
wanted to go back to los angeles he used
this um tryout as an excuse
because he wanted to go home and be with
his new girlfriend
and he makes uh this
show he makes the cast of this show that
eventually put him in a teen magazine
that got him on the board for the
outsiders which he got the day
he was ready to just try something new
and go to usc as a marine biologist
i i mean look we we all have something
that we want to figure out in life
um and and wonder if our dreams can come
true
and you know you do need luck that
he did in fact get this call for the
outsiders just as he was getting set to
become a marine biologist yeah but
there's also as he said not paying
attention to
the odds he said he was ignorant of the
odds
but now that he's aware of the odds
in retrospect um the odds that
you could go to hollywood and go to los
angeles get
wind up in malibu live next door to the
sheen family
and then get your own opportunity by
riding the bus and
humping it and giving up a little bit of
your normal childhood to go
chase a dream we all can take something
from that i think
you know i know i try to give something
portable to everybody on every single
episode of just getting started
and maybe it's just hey
don't pay attention to the odds the odds
might be against you but why not me
is what he said why not you so
you know as this economy and this world
is opening up and we're all getting back
to
hopefully a normal life why not you
why not take a chance why not go for
something that you want to achieve
why not you is a great i think
um line and question to take out of this
and best of luck between now and the
next time
we took a couple weeks off but we're
back next week
kelsey grammer who got his start on
cheers and more
it'll be a great conversation with the
man who brought frasier crane to you and
it looks like he's going to bring
frasier crane back to you as well can't
wait to chat with him on the next
episode of just getting started
see you then